هاي انتم لن نسمح لكم باهانتنا مره اخرى
وقد اعذر من انذر نعم بولندا تهدد زيلنسكي
بهذه العباره لتتدخل الولايات المتحده
لايقاف البولنديين عند حدهم ما الذي يجري
رئيس الوزراء الكندي يدخل رجله في بحر
الحرب الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا تعلن ضرب مقر
قيادات الجيش الروسي في القرن وبريطانيا
للاوكران لا تقلقوا نحن معكم مهما طال
الامر ومهما كلفنا ذلك فلتسند اقتصادكم
اولا ثم اسندوا اوكرانيا سلاح الجو الروسي
يعزز نفسه بسلاح جديد وتسريب استخباراتي
يتحدث عن عشره الاف مشكله فنيه في سلاح
الجو الامريكي افريقيا تقول كفى للظلم
الاوروبي والامريكي معا اسرائيل وامريكا
تخطبان ود السعوديه مجددا فهل تقبل الرياض
اعلان الصين تايوان تعيش رعبا غير مسبوق
فولندا تشعل نار العداء لا شيء السابق ولا
الحلفاء بقوا على عهدهم حتى الجيران يا
ساده اصبحوا يقولونها بالفم المليان
للاوكران لا تتجاوز حدودكم هي بولندا وعلى
لسان رئيس وزرائها ماتيوش مورسكي تحذر
الرئيس الاوكراني
جديده بحق وارسوك وقال مورفيتسكي اريد ان
نقول للزلمسكي الا يهين البولنديين مره
اخرى بالطريقه التي اهنهم مؤخرا خلال
خطابه في الامم المتحده البولنديون لن
يسمحوا بذلك ابدا الرساله واضحه فهل فهمها
الرد ياتي من الولايات المتحده بذاتها هذه
المره حيث نقلت عن مسؤول رافع
طلبت من بولندا تفسيرات بشان قرارها وقف
الدعم لكييف وشرى المسؤول الى ان موقف
وارسو المحدد بشان دعم اوكرانيا لا يزال
غير واضحا بانتظار التوضيح البولندي لنرى
رده فعل واشنطن ولكن خلال ذلك هناك من
يقدم الاعطيات لزلنسكي وبلاده حيث كان
رئيس الوزراء الكندي قد اعلن خلال زياره
الرئيس الاوكراني الى العاصمه الكنديه
اوتاوا عن حزمه مساعدات تبلغ قيمتها 650
مليون دولار كندي فيما فاد موقع بانشبونج
نيوز ان رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
يعتزم سحب ثلاثمائه مليون دولار من
ميزانيه الدفاع الامريكيه المخصصه لتدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه فيا لها من مجزره عنيفه
للميزانيه الامريكيه لتعد كندا وتقف مع
الاوكران مجددا لكن هذه المره بفرض عقوبات
على الروس حيث اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الكنديه اضافه حكومه البلاد احدى وعشرين
منظمه واثنتين واربعين شخصيه روسيه الى
قوائم العقوبات المفروضه ضد موسكو يبدو ان
الكنديين يبحثون عن اغضاب الد الروسي باي
طريقه وبذات الطريقه تمضي بريطانيا ايضا
حيث قال نائب رئيس الوزراء البريطاني خلال
كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
ستقف المملكه المتحده الى جانب اوكرانيا
مهما كلف الامر
بل ولسنوات اذا اقتضت الضروره ليحمل وزير
خارجيه روسيس مسؤوليه الرد على عاتقه
وخلال المناقشه السياسيه العامه للدوره 78
للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اكد ان
الامريكيين والاوروبيين الذين اعتادوا
النظر الى بقيه العلم باستخفاف كثيرا ما
يقدمون الوعود وياخذون على عاتقهم
التزامات مكتوبه وملزمه قانونا ثم لا
ينفذونها ببساطه مضيفا وكما لاحظ الرئيس
بلادي فان الغرب امبراطوريه الاكاذيب
الحقيقيه
[موسيقى]
فيما جاء الرد الروسي بتنفيذ موسكو 59
ضربه جويه على الجيش الاوكراني خلال 24
ساعه اليكم المصدر على الجبهات القتاليه
في اوكرانيا مع اعلان حاكم تفعيل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي وسقوط حطام صاروخ في احدى
مناطق المدينه صباح اليوم السبت خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه الحديث عن 59 ضربه جويه
نفذتها القوات الروسيه على مواقع تابعه
للقوات الاوكرانيه خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
وكانت الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت عن سقوط
نحو 4000 جندي اوكراني ما بين قتيل وجريح
خلال الفتره من السابعه عشر وحتى الثالث
والعشرين من سبتمبر الجهريه في مناطق
متفرقه في نطاق العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه بحسب وكاله سبوتنيك العالميه اضافت
الدفاع انه خلال المعارك الجويه دمرت
المقاتلات الروسيه وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
خلال مقاتلات سوق 24 و29
وطائرتين هجوميتين من طراز سو 25 كلها
تابعه لسلاح الجو الاوكراني في مناطق
نيكولاي ايفلوج ومن الغرب الاوكرانيه الى
معارك اسلحه الجو المرعبه حيث افاد المكتب
الصحفي لشركه روستيخ الحكوميه ان الشركه
سلمت القوات الجويه الروسيه طائره الكشف
الراداري بعيد المدى
وقالت الشركه ان الطائره يمكنها اكتشاف
انواع جديده من الطائرات كما انها قادره
على رصد عدد اكبر من الاهداف والمسيرات في
وقت واحد مقارنه مع سابقتها
القدرات المرعبه في المقابل كشف تقرير
حكومي امريكي ان نصف مقاتلات اف 35 شبحيه
الامريكيه تحتاج الى ترليون وثلاثمائه
مليار دولار حتى تستطيع الطيران رغم من
المفترض ان تلك الطائرات دخلت الخدمه
فعليا ولفت التقرير الى ان المستويات
الحاليه لاسطول مقاتلات 35 غير مقبوله
مشيرا الى ان هناك تاخرا عن الجدول الزمني
بسبب عشره الاف مشكله فنيه يتم اصلاحها
ونحن نتحدث عن اقوى سلاح جوي للولايات
المتحده الاحداث والتطورات قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان هناك فرصه للتوصل الى اتفاق سلام مع
السعوديه خلال الاشهر القليله المقبله او
سيتم تاجيله لعده سنوات واضاف نتنياهو ان
الفلسطينيين يجب ان يكونوا جزءا من
الاتفاق واما بامكانهم الاستفاده منه لكن
مهلا مهلا ما كل هذا التراجع من اسرائيل
هل هو لخطب ود السعوديه حقا ام ان هناك
مارب اخرى لتل ابيب وعلى ذكر اعلنت وكاله
الامن والتعاون الدفاعي الامريكي اختار
الكونغرس بموافقه وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
على حزمه مبيعات عسكريه محتمله للسعوديه
بقيمه 5000 مليون دولار والى تايوان قال
وزير الدفاع التايواني ان التزايد وتيره
الانشطه العسكريه الصينيه حول تايوان
مؤخرا يزيد من احتمال خروج الاحداث عن
نطاق السيطره ووقوع اشتباك وقالت تايوان
الصين اجرت خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين
تدريبات عسكريه بالقرب من الجزيره شاركت
فيها عشرات المقاتلات والمسيرات بالاضافه
الى السفن الحربيه وحامله الطائرات
الصينيه والى افريقيا قال رئيس
انه حان الوقت للاعتراف بان الكثير من
ثروات اوروبا وامريكا جمعت من دماء
الافارقه واضاف خلال كلمته بالجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده انه يجب على تلك
الدول ان تدفع تعويضات عن تجاره العبيد
لمعالجه ما وصفه بالظلم التاريخي
[موسيقى]